I would like for you to picture the
first time you kissed someone you really
like how did you feel
did you have this funny feeling in your
stomach were you flying few inches above
the ground maybe this is an example of
something that I call a good bump moment
I love good bump moment they make me
feel present they make me feel connected
and they make me feel alive and there
are three things that never fail to give
me goosebumps
apart from kissing climbing mountains
this is me climbing Mont Blanc in Europe
last summer listening to my favorite
music
MPs tomorrow with my friends we are
going to Los Angeles to see Red Hot
Chili Peppers live in their home city
I'm so excited for this
and finally basically everything about
space exploration and today I would like
to share with you my favorite moments in
the history of space exploration let's
begin our journey with our one and only
natural satellites you all know as the
moon you know the story everything
started in late 1950s two super
countries decided to join the space race
and send people to the most expensive
picnic in a history of humankind
yes picnic even though it costs two
hundred billion dollars by today's value
of money two hundred billion dollar
landing on the moon had no major
scientific value this is literally what
I was told when I was visiting Kennedy
Space Center last summer but yet it
gives me goosebumps even now when I'm
thinking about it ever since life began
on our planet 3.8 billion years ago this
is the first time we managed to leave
our planet and and land on another
astronomical body the same astronomical
body that our ancestors had been seen
for thousands and thousands of years on
the clear night sky but could never
reach can you imagine that NASA was
founded in 1958 and managed to put
humans on the moon in only 11 years I
mean YouTube is 12 years old and it's
it's not even profitable probably let me
tell you about my favorite goosebump
moments from that time you've probably
all seen the sunrise or the moonrise
right there is a picture from the time
which is my favorite and it's called the
airfryer I like this picture so much
that I even printed it framed and it's
sitting in my apartment back in Poland
where I'm from this picture was taken by
an astronaut William Anders on Christmas
Eve 1968 and the reason why I put this
picture in my apartment is to remind me
to always always keep everything in a
proper perspective you see ever since
famous astronomer meet Ally Kaepernick
or Nicholas Copernicus as you may know
him in English
we knew that we are we knew that we are
not the center of the universe but now
for the first time we could actually see
it let me put it this way when you were
a child
your whole universe your whole world was
just your house and maybe a backyard and
then when you were growing up your world
was expanding to your school to your
neighborhood to the whole city to other
cities to the whole country to other
countries and for some of us even
continents with every new perspective
you will remember new place you get a
new perspective and that's exactly why
the air price is so important this is
the first time we as humanity gain these
new perspectives collectively for that
reason the earth price was dubbed one of
the most important pictures in the
history of humankind it's a symbol for
calls to global unity and peace and it
also started modern environmental
movement
so living on the moon and getting this
new perspective is our first good month
moment in the next 40 40 years we did to
to space exploration the same thing
Michael Jordan did to basketball
we made going to space look easy so we
kept going we perform the staggering 131
successful launches launches of space
shuttle we built a big baddest camera
called called Hubble Space Telescope
that we put into space to take pictures
of deep space we've also created a
flying club called the International
Space Station where we can conduct
experiments in microgravity beginning of
1970s we started sending out a number of
elements spacecraft in order to explore
beyond our loaf low-earth orbit there is
probably eight of them that are
important but my favorite by far is
Voyager 1 Voyager 1 was launched in 1977
so 40 years ago and currently it's 20
billion kilometres from Planet Earth
it's the first object to leave our solar
system in the history of humankind
and also since the beginning of my
speech it already traveled 3,000 miles
which makes it also the fastest object
we ever created the original mission of
the voyager was to take pictures of
Jupiter and Saturn and this brings me to
my second favorite goosebumps moment
after passing Jupiter NASA decided to
turn Voyager around and take the last
picture of our solar system from a
distance here is the part of this
picture in the middle you can see a tiny
dot over there let me help you
this tiny dot is our planet and this
picture is called the pale blue dot it
has its a it's not beautiful and it
again it has no major scientific value
but let me quote fragments what famous
astronomer Carl Sagan set about this
picture
that's home on it everyone you ever
heard of every young couple in love
every hope food child every mother and
father every saint and sinner in the
history of our species lived there on a
mote of dust suspended in a sunbeam our
imagined self-importance the delusion
that we have some privileged position in
the universe are challenged by this
point of pale light it underscores our
responsibility to deal more kindly with
one another and to preserve and cherish
the pale blue dot the only home we've
ever known whereas the air price was
about perspective the pale blue dot
reminds me how vast the universe is and
you can get intimidated by looking at
this display of blue dot but also you
can turn around and get excited of how
much more is there to explore and then
brings me to current days and oh boy
it's hard not to get goosebumps it's so
many things happening all the time
just recently Elon Musk announced that
he is about to send to private citizens
for a round trip around the moon as soon
as M 2018 his company SpaceX promises to
land humans on Mars just nine years from
now nine years NASA promises the same
but I'm not only talking about the big
players I'm talking also about startups
like planet labs that produces small
efficient ex-mo like this efficient
satellites that are capable of taking
high-definition pictures of our our
planet's surface or the other startups
called made in space they produce the
first zero gravity 3d printer that
operates currently onboard the ISS the
International Space Station with all
those things happening do you know what
what what give me goosebumps when I
think about the future I had this little
dream you know that I like mountains
right there is a mountain on Mars
it's called Olympus Mons it's 2.5 times
taller that the tallest mountain on
earth Mount Everest and in fact is the
tallest mountain in our solar system
can you imagine climbing this baby and
listening to other side by your coochie
peppers on top of it this is crazy but
yet it's it's it's totally possible in
my lifespan I hope you get a little at
least a little bit excited about space
at space exploration and maybe some of
you even got some good bump moments let
me finish my speech when one last remark
every TED like speech has some tangible
idea that can change your life change
organizations or change the world you
may wonder what is the tangible idea in
my speech well you're right there is
none my message to you is simply stop
overthinking for a second stop looking
for logic all the time tonight get out
put your favorite music on and look up
at the stars get yourself a good
component thank you
you
[Music]